My name is Lucerito Ortiz.
I’m from North Hills, California.
My parents are
two of the hardest-working people.
My dad works in gardening.
My mom found work as a housekeeper.
We have a big family.
We have to find ways to save
as much as we can.
I learned to sew.
We have chickens, so that way
we don’t have to buy eggs.
They’re very, very delicious.
Much better than store-bought eggs.
And we cook at home.
It’s different ways to save money.
They’ll sacrifice anything and everything
for their children...
and they’ve worked incredibly hard
to get us to where we are.
My daughter is a very, very
responsible person...
and she loved school.
But I ended up applying
sort of as a joke, as a dare.
A couple of friends and I were
out on the track one day, just chatting.
We just said–
We were laughing–
“It would be so funny
if you applied to Harvard.
We could frame your rejection letter.”
One day, Lucerito called me...
and she said,
“Mom, guess what.”
The letter was there.
I was on the phone with my mom.
I said, “Mom, hold on.”
And then she said,
“Mom, I was accepted at Harvard.”
I ran all over my house,
just yelling and screaming...
and told my whole family...
and we were all just in utter shock.
My husband and I talked about,
“We don’t have the money.”
I found out that for a family like ours...
we wouldn’t have to worry
about affording Harvard.
Harvard has such an amazing
financial aid program...
that for us, in reality,
it was much more affordable...
than attending any of the state schools.
I really, really admire her,
and I’m so proud of her.
For me, Harvard wasn’t just for me...
it was for my whole family...
and I think my whole family
has benefited immensely...
from our experience at Harvard.
It’s an incredible feeling...
to feel like I was finally able
to give something back to my family...
after everything they sacrificed for me.